it's been a longer wait than anyone
would like but finally the fast saga is
back
following a number of delays f9 is
scheduled to hit theaters on june 25th
2021 and universal is starting to ramp
up the hype by releasing a brand new
trailer
there's a lot happening in the new f9
trailer including several treats for
long time fans of the series
here are a few that you may have missed
the new f9 trailer begins with a few
scenes of domestic harmony
including a brief clip of dom played by
vin diesel watching a video of his best
friend brian o'connor played by the late
paul walker and a scene of michelle
rodriguez's letty playing with dom's son
brian
if you pause the video on that last one
you'll notice letty and brian are
playing with a tank a car and a space
shuttle the car looks a lot like dom's
beloved dodge charger while the tank is
a callback to a memorable scene from
fast and furious 6.
that space shuttle though is even more
interesting as the new trailer's final
seconds reveal f9 has finally taken the
franchise into space
something that fans have wanted for
years as little brian makes the toy car
fly through the air it lands on the back
of letty's shuttle
mirroring the trailer's last scene
speaking of dom's family john cena may
be a newcomer to the fast and furious
franchise but his character jacob is no
stranger to dom
jacob is dom's brother
just to drive the point home check out
jacob's costume in his first scene in
the new trailer jacob wears a silver
cross necklace that looks exactly the
same as the one dom wears throughout the
series
in the fourth movie dom gives the
necklace to letty and later finds it at
the scene of her seemingly fatal car
crash
then in fast and furious 6 dom uses the
necklace to remind letty of who she used
to be
it's also implanted with a tracking
device in the fate of the furious so the
dom can keep tabs on the sun
for tom the necklace is a potent symbol
so it's a big deal that jacob wears one
too
after all despite their differences
jacob and tom are family and as we all
know that's what the fast saga is all
about
according to the fast saga there's
nothing nas can't do
in the first fast and furious movie
brian o'connor uses nas
short for nitrous oxide to up his speed
during his first race against dom
toretto
it doesn't quite work but nas has been a
franchise staple ever since
while nasa's primary purpose is to give
vehicles a quick speed boost it's had a
few other uses in the series as well
in too fast too furious nas powers the
ejector seats in brian and roman's cars
in fast and furious a noz fueled
explosion blows up a number of vehicles
creating a distraction the dom uses to
secure his freedom
in fast five dom hits the nas button in
order to drag the vault the crew is
stealing which lets the other drivers
get away
now it looks like niles will send the
fast crew to the stars
in the new f9 trailer's final scene
there's a canister of nas complete with
its distinctive logo sitting between tez
and roman
presumably that's what fuels their
rocket bound car and gives them the push
they need to escape the atmosphere
scientifically speaking that's probably
not all that accurate
but we'll let it slide lastly while the
fast and furious series is fast-paced
action scenes would be exciting even in
complete silence its music
takes everything to the next level
unsurprisingly the f9 trailer sports
some pretty great tunes too
at the beginning of the trailer while
the extended toretto clan assembles you
can hear the chainsmokers family playing
in the background
if you know anything about the fast saga
you know why that's appropriate
the entire song is an ode to the type of
found family that gives these movies
their heart
it's hard to imagine a better choice
[Music]
salute me familiar
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the fast and the furious franchise are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you